Julia…
JULIA.
WHAT!?
Hey guys Julia here for DNews
Have you guys ever been on a train playing
on your phone and suddenly you’ve missed
your train stop?
Or if you’re like me, your family thinks
you’ve suddenly gone deaf when you’ve
got your nose stuck in a book.
This has become an actual recurring problem
in my life.
But aha!
Science vindicates me!
Apparently focusing on something visual does
makes us kind of deaf.
It happens to most of us.
It’s called “inattentional deafness”
according to a study published in the journal
Attention, Perception, & Psychophysics.
The researchers tested over 100 participants
and had them focus on tasks on a computer
screen and they played a noticeable tone.
When the task demanded more attention, eight
out of ten participants failed to notice the
tone.
And this isn’t exactly news.
Humans aren’t that good at paying attention
to lots of different things at the same time.
We can focus, we just can’t pay attention.
Researchers have known for years about “inattentional
blindness”, which like it sounds is when
you don’t see something happening because
you were focused on something else.
The classic example is the “invisible gorilla
test”.
Where you watch people pass a basket ball
back and forth and count how many times they
passed it.
But in the middle of the video a person in
a gorilla suit walks in, beats their chest,
and walks out.
In one study of this video, 42% of people
didn’t notice the gorilla.
At all because they were so focused on the
basketball.
So what’s going on?
Well a recent study published in the Journal
of Neuroscience found our brains aren’t
as efficient as we’d like to think.
In this small study, researchers hooked up
13 volunteers to a brain activity measuring
device called a MEG.
This machine is used to measure how long it
takes for an “unusual sensory signal”
to get from your brain to your consciousness.
Basically, how long it takes for you to recognize
something after you see or hear it.
This typically takes 300msec, and is referred
to as a p3 reading .
In the study the volunteers were given a visually
demanding task, like matching things on a
computer.
While they were engrossed in their task, the
researchers played a tone.
The scientists found that the volunteers were
so focused on matching things, their P3 response
was suppressed.
Which means they didn’t consciously perceive
the sound.
And another reading suggested that they didn’t
even hear it.
The MEG also looked at activity in the superior
temporal sulcus and posterior middle temporal
gyrus, which are parts of our brain that usually
light up in response to hearing a sound.
But since the volunteers were so focused on
the task, even this reading was weak.
So really, when you’re focusing really hard
on something, your brain barely hears it and
it doesn’t even reach your consciousness.
The researchers found that this is because
the senses of hearing and vision share a limited
neural resource.
Simply put, your brain doesn’t have the
resources to consciously perceive multiple
things at the same time.
So take that mom and dad!
I wasn’t ignoring you when I was reading,
I literally couldn’t hear you!